se tu é desenvolvedor
e a arquitetura de software chega pra tu pronta
só pra tu implementar
ela tem um problema
que não tá escrito em nenhum lugar
isso porque o arquiteto entende o negócio
ele decide as tecnologias
e passa pro desenvolvedor implementar
problema é que nada volta
então quando o desenvolvedor muda
alguma coisa no meio do caminho
o arquiteto nunca fica sabendo
por isso
o melhor é o time devolver pra quem desenhou
o que mudou e o que ele descobriu
eu aprendi isso quando eu precisei tomar decisões como
arquiteto
acostumada a ser um desenvolvedor
e daí uma vez eu passei
alguns meses desenhando uma pipeline de processamento
que basicamente
por questões de domínio
utilizava ali o banco relacionado como uma fila
e só foi andar de fato
quando eu fui conversar com quem tava no time
há mais tempo que a galera conhecia os problemas
que não tava no código e nem documentado
e eles tinham vivido o problema quando ele aconteceu
depois disso
o desenho fechou mais rápido
a mudança da implementação
era rápida de atualizar na arquitetura toda
então quando o time devolve o que descobriu
a solução fica melhor
porque leva em conta problemas que só o time conhecia
conta aqui no teu time
quando o desenvolvedor muda alguma coisa na arquitetura
quem desenhou também fica sabendo